[Música]
y hace unos años me di cuenta que no lo
estaba haciendo solía ser una de esas
personas que pensaba que la felicidad
llegaba de repente que era un estado al
cual llegaba después de alcanzar metas
tenía muchas ideas preconcebidas de lo
que era muchas de ellas marcadas por lo
que quería la sociedad por lo que era
aceptable de acuerdo a la edad en la que
estaba
empecé a fijarme metas muy altas
pensando que cuando consiguiera esas
metas iba a ser sumamente feliz
pero todo lo contrario al empezar a
conseguirlas en lugar de sentirme
orgullosa o satisfecha
empecé a vivir una vida
déjenme los ponga en contexto una vida
que para mí fue una etapa de
indiferencia
una etapa donde no quería socializar
porque sabía que hacerlo implicaba
contestar muchas preguntas que me hacían
sentir incómoda
recuerdo en una reunión que me
preguntaban cosas sobre asuntos que ya
había dicho antes me decían oye que una
con tu clase de fotografía y yo puedes
fíjate que ya no averigüen nada se acabó
la promoción en facebook y pues ya no
hice nada
y que querías aprender otro idioma no es
con tanto trabajo ya ni se puede y el
viaje que tenías planeado no pues no se
puede e incluso con preguntas tan
simples como estas
y así apatía indiferencia me volví muy
ermitaño muchas veces me costaba trabajo
quitarme la pijama estaba desmotivado
empecé a tener muy malos hábitos estaba
ansiosa nerviosa pero no me daba cuenta
de esto hasta una vez que fui al súper
ir al súper es una actividad que me
choca y cuando estaba ahí para quienes
me conocen saben que las cejas se me
pone hasta acá cuando estoy enojada está
agarrando una bolsa en el pasillo de
frutas y verduras y de repente de un
niño
un niño que va a tomar un melón y lo
primero que pensé fue ya va a ser un
desastre y se acerca con su mamá y le
dice
[Música]
esto y la mamá le contesta un melón
mijito te encanta el agua de melón
va toma ahora otra piña otra fruta era
una piña se acerca con ella y le dice
mamá y esto una piña mijito mira tocada
toca cómo se siente y así durante otras
tres más
yo me quedé viendo espero que ellos no
se hayan dado cuenta y sentí como mis
cejas se empezó a bajar
como mi corporalidad empezará a cambiar
y ahora se dibuja una sonrisa
también me quedé pensando porque no
puedo ser más como ese niño
dónde está mi capacidad de asombro
porque estoy molesta por tener que hacer
una actividad que desde el día a día la
mamá también me dejó pensando cómo puedo
dar respuestas más constructivas de
verdad que no le bajó el ánimo al niño
he visto otras como haya olvídalo no y
ella no
como psicóloga organizacional siempre
había pensado que puede hacer una
empresa para que el empleado sea más
productivo o que se sienta mejor pero
después de esta llega al súper después
de analizar mi propia vida me di cuenta
que el interrogante tenía que ir todavía
un paso más atrás
qué puedo hacer para motivar a las
personas a la acción qué puedo hacer yo
para dejar de contestar
y empezar a tener respuestas que
realmente me llenen me llenen de vida
afortunadamente mi trabajo era el único
aspecto donde no me sentía me ahí me
sentía competente autónoma y me gustaban
muchos los retos uno de los retos más
importantes que llegó a mí fue
incorporar la psicología positiva a la
cultura organizacional primero pensé
como o sea a mí que ahorita me siento
tan mal como voy a hacer eso pero
entusiasmada por los retos decidí
convertirme en mi propio sujeto de
estudio si las investigaciones decían
que para estar más feliz tienes que
hacer más ejercicio lo iba a ser si
tienes que convivir con más personas lo
iba a hacer
tenía que incomodar me salir de esa zona
de confort
lo primero que hice fue medir mi
bienestar físico las investigaciones
dicen que tenemos que dar 10.000 pasos
diarios por esas fechas me regalaron una
pulserita cuenta pasos y me acuerdo que
el primer día que me la puse yo estaba
100% segura de que iba a llegar al
número tenía que caminar del
estacionamiento a la oficina a subir
cuatro pisos luego en lo que comía todo
ese trayecto etcétera
pero cuando llega la noche y veo cuántos
pasos había dado me quedé
de verdad creo que las investigaciones
están exagerando y eso de los 10.000
pasos es para gente maratonista gente
muy activa pero continué midiendo me leí
un término por ahí que me gustó que
hablaba de los snacks de ejercicio que
quiere decir que tengas pequeños
movimientos en tu día a día que le sumen
más pasos como por ejemplo en lugar de
tomar un elevador ahora tenía que tomar
las escaleras si podía estacionar me un
poquito más lejos lo iba a hacer y así
poco a poco empecé a sumar más y más
movimientos y no sólo el número de pasos
subió también empezó a subir mi estado
de ánimo
ahora me sentía mejor con más energía
con más ganas de desayunar porque sabía
que iba a tener que distribuir esa
energía etcétera estaba fascinada
pensaba como con algo tan sencillo te
puedes hacer más feliz
y así continúe decidir hacer un
certificado de psicología positiva
aplicada ahora me estaban enseñando cómo
poder estar más aquí cómo activar
nuestros sentidos qué podemos hacer para
dejar el romeo y empezar a sentir
curiosa por la felicidad de los demás
empecé un proyecto me di la tarea de ir
con personas random a preguntarles qué
es lo que te hace feliz a ti como este
proyecto lo empecé en nueva york pensé
que era una muy buena ciudad para
empezar total si la gente me decía que
no quería contestar pues sin carlos iba
a volver a ver en mi vida y me llevé
sorpresas muy gratas las personas
querían contestar querían compartir
al escucharlos al entrevistarlos me
empecé a dar cuenta que eran mis propias
ideas las que me estaban alejando de
esto de ser feliz que la felicidad no es
algo tan ambiguo y que depende de muchas
cosas que nosotros mismos decidamos
hacer
creo que para poder aplicar la
psicología positiva primero tenemos que
partir de la humildad de reconocer
cuáles son aquellos hábitos que tenemos
que nos hacen estar bien pero también
reconocer cuáles son aquellos hábitos
que no están sumando que no nos están
dando bienestar
por eso hoy los quiero invitar a ustedes
a que se conviertan en su propio sujeto
de estudio dejen de lado las ideas que
les han dicho de lo que es la felicidad
porque cada persona es diferente de
verdad al entrevistar a las personas
porque ya llevo dos años haciendo esto
me he dado cuenta que el dolor es
compartido todos somos seres humanos
todos tenemos miedos todos tenemos
inseguridades pero también todos
buscamos ser feliz
experimenta más la vida sal de aquí
punto aquí
si gente vive apasionante date tiempo
para hacer lo que te gusta tienes que
dedicarle tiempo y te va a costar
trabajo puede que te incomode es pero no
dejes de medirlo porque si no lo mides
no vas a ver si hay un avance o no la
felicidad no es algo ambiguo aquí está
falta que lo experimentes y si todavía
no sabes qué es lo que te hace feliz
me gustaría compartirles un vídeo con
una compilación breve de algunas de las
entrevistas
pero cada persona
y después
[Música]
son muchas cosas
mis amigos
[Música]
es la música
trabajar y como todos
[Música]
ese día
tarde
una posibilidad
nuestra vida
andar en bicicleta
un tipo
[Música]
[Aplausos]